vice president kamala harris made a stop
in las vegas today to talk
infrastructure thanks for staying with
us here for this special edition of
eight news now
i'm sasha loftis this is all part of her
america back together tour she visited
the carpenters international training
center near las vegas boulevard and
sunset
madison kimbrough joins us live tonight
with the latest madison
yeah as you can see we are here at the
d.i overpass one of the busiest roadways
here in las vegas
and our city's infrastructure was the
main topic of kamala harris's visit
today
the vice president asking for support
from the community
on the administration's plan to create
the largest infrastructure project in
america
the 1.2 trillion dollar plan is meant to
improve sustainable transportation
options
by improving and rebuilding roads and
bridges and expanding transit and rail
networks across the country
it also focuses on climate change
mitigations clean water resources with
the removal of
lead service lines and pipes and
reliable connectivity with high-speed
internet
vice president harris noting that our
infrastructure here in nevada
desperately needs an upgrade
here in nevada there are 28 bridges
in poor condition there are more than a
thousand miles of highway
in need of repair and i don't need to
tell you this you all know it
you drive on these roads every day there
are people
in this state who do not have access to
affordable high-speed internet
or who do not have clean drinking water
coming out of their tap
the republican national committee
responding to vice president harris's
visit today with this statement quote
under this administration nevada has the
fifth highest unemployment
the fourth highest gas prices and
highest coveted 19 case rate
in the country the only thing nevadans
want to hear from kamala harris this
weekend
is how she and joe biden intend to
address their failures
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now